[Music]
i would love to
chat with you about something that i
think a lot of my listeners will be very
interested in certainly i'll be
interested in exploring a bit and and
that is
what seems like a predilection to resist
labels and or being labeled being
claimed for causes you wrote an essay
titled on being a woman writer which got
a lot of attention is it fair to say
that you resist
labels being labeled and if so
why
why is that how would you explain that i
resist closed boxes
okay
the reason i resist closed boxes is that
nature does not deal in closed boxes
yeah it doesn't if if it did there
wouldn't have been any evolution
if it did you and i would not exist
so everything in nature is on a bell
curve
and there are a lot of
liminal beings or let's say
forms that cannot be put into closed
boxes
such as for instance the platypus
so i just don't like closed boxes and
labels are a way of of filing people
you know oh you're at this we're going
to file you there
and under this you know
letter
your box is going to go there and that's
who you are and that's all you are and
and i don't think that's true of anyone
and i do think we all contain
multitudes so that's probably why and
you can say sure i'm a woman writer
i'm a woman i'm a writer
but that's not the end of the story
there have been a lot of women writers
and not all of them are exactly like me
so we we don't
you can you can put a general heading
over something just as you can put a
general heading over science fiction
speculative fiction
stories about werewolves
you know dracula frankenstein ghost
stories they're all wonder tales
you can call them all undertale so you
can call all women writers women writers
but that's not the end of the story
there's a lot of other things
that can be added to that
so
dracula is not the same as
war of the worlds
they're both wonder tales but they're
very different
like that
so sure let's say
woman writer 82
generational okay
country
city height
hair curly
that's important tim yeah
so like that so you can you can build
out the picture you can you can start
with a few labels but it's not the whole
story for anybody
and if you're a novelist of course you
deal in individuals
so you're not just doing types
does that make any sense to you it makes
perfect sense makes perfect sense and
it's
you know i think that
labels are also dangerous because if you
assume them for yourself
you're more inclined if you get attached
to them to want to defend
those labels as a facet or as the sole
entirety of your
identity and that's i think how we end
up in a lot of the places where we find
ourselves collectively now yeah well
people attach labels to other people and
then they attack the label and that has
been going on for at least five thousand
years as far as we know yeah a few years
yeah quite a few years so that's that's
a thing that if we wish to live in them
in a
multiple democracy
we should
attempt to go beyond labels
and of course what people then go is
well you're a feminist and then i always
have to say what kind of feminist
are you talking about right because
there's at least 75 different kinds
so am i the kind that thinks all men
should be rounded up and shoved off a
cliff except for 10 kept for breeding no
i am not that kind
you will be happy to note him
yes i think you're happy to know
thank you you want to be kept for
breeding do you no you don't i want to
be kept for breeding yes please keep
breathing
maybe not maybe not depends on the it
really depends on how that's all
organized
yeah you know i should probably think
more before i answer these types of
things
you